I'll do that earlier really it's part of
my job how you do it easy I got slapped
in the face
good morning guys
so today Casey and I will be meal
prepping because our schedules have been
so crazy recently that we really don't
have a chance to actually sit down and
have like a nice family meal where we
actually get to cook together and like
get to actually bond through cooking so
right now Isaac's at school and because
he's at school and Casey's meeting
starts in a couple hours we actually
have this small little tiny window of
opportunity to actually cook and get
some meal prep in and so we're gonna be
doing that right now so Casey's already
getting started downstairs so let's go
see what he's up to
hey hey my baby hello good morning good
morning
hmm Oh did you tell about the blurry
clipping
no I forgot it sorry guy so it's so
exciting because we actually got the
opportunity to partner with blue apron
and blue apron it's a food delivery
service type of thing right yeah I'm
actually really excited about this is
because they sent us stuff that I would
never actually buy at a grocery store so
they're actually opening my mind up to
cooking things I would actually cook
myself because I'm not familiar with
cooking with beets and they sent us a
beat so I'm like or chives your kind
whatever I which I've I never cook Greek
yogurt never touch the stuff either so
I'm actually really excited I didn't
know this
you know what Pharaoh is no it looks
like brown rice but it's called Pharaoh
borrow pot and roll five overall it's
pretty cool like having this opportunity
to partner up with them because Casey is
usually the cook here but with blue
apron and because of the fact that they
give us ingredients that are perfectly
proportioned so that the recipe and they
actually give us instructions I can feel
like I'm the cook in this house too man
we're gonna be cooking pastrami spice
salmon with pickled beet relish and
cauliflower bondo salad yeah so that's
we're gonna be meal prepping cuz this is
actually for a serving of for four
people
so we actually chose the family plan but
they also have a two-person plan
available on their site and it's pretty
cool with all of their meals like they
can all be prepared and less than an
hour or I guess they say 40 minutes so
to be specific about 40 minutes or less
and of you guys click on the link in the
description box below the first 50 of
you guys to order their blue apron will
get their first three meals for free so
check it out and go quickly before
they're all gone
do you ever get hungry stereo raw
ingredients as I do first Harvey oh no I
don't I said earlier that both salmon
well I guess it looks like sushi think
about it oh yeah it does looks pretty
good okay the only time I've ever
experienced that was the remember that
one time we went to the aquarium and we
started single is but it doesn't say
keep encroachers I know
I know that was the only time I ever
felt where I was like oh man it feels so
weird but that fish is looking really
good
cuz they really love sushi barbaric I'm
pretty tired you're a liar cuz it that
same day that we were there you're like
and these fish looked good and I was
like I was thinking the exact same thing
that's when I saw the shrimp
I saw the live shrimp down but never
mind seemed like sweet shrimp at like
the sushi places when they actually have
to look at the shrimp life but you were
looking at like like finding dory you're
like no I'm emo you're like me no we're
just looking at some fish probably that
I don't know but like yeah like these
kind of raw ingredients so like I don't
look at it and think God's gonna be
delicious
I don't unless it's a fruit depends on
which side of it we look at if you look
just at this part that could look pretty
appetizing just that right there but
then you look at that right there
it doesn't look as advertising media
back alright so we're gonna get started
on this cookin
choking up doing like I guess I guess
myself conscious of like am I doing this
right be like am i cutting its how it's
supposed to be cut like am i holding
this the way people help
cuz like I remember when I was helping
David one time we're juicing is that was
just like chopping up all the vegetable
defense and he sees me you're chopping
it up and he's like okay so he comes
over to me he's like teaching me how I
shall hold in how I should be cutting
he's like you should never hear the of
that cuz yeah you know you're not doing
it right you're not you're not actually
chopping it's like yeah I do it I'm
still doing that it takes time it's a
Muslim everything cuz of all night like
it's so much thinking and like so much
like you need to do it this way in that
way love love there's so many ways that
you can be wrong that I just get
intimidating I'm just I got forget it
the kitchen not for me but I mean I
guess I'm trying here I think what
chances does it look more and more
delicious I think so
good yeah look from that that doesn't
look as edible as that so if every step
of the way it looks more and more edible
than I think you're doing alright we'll
see you know I know that I suck at
cooking
I'm pretty bad because then whenever I
cook something for I think he's always
like no you like my cooking I think
you'll cook he's like oh man
delicious no my horse Casey made it he
just has a very limited palette for now
I wish I had a magic trick scope go away
we do have the editing magic oh let's do
it real quick alright magic trick
commence yeah
Hey looks more edible now baby gave us a
little bag here and inside this how cute
it's like perfectly proportionate is
apple cider vinegar Oh
I freaked out over little things I don't
know why I'm so weird and then you know
it's awesome that we don't think wasting
the ingredients either cuz it's like
that's the exact amount that we need
that's so true I love it
you
a My Little Chef yeah how's it going
good
I think it's going pretty good I'm
feeling confident now a little more
confident because it's all so easy
but you're not really involved because
every time you cook you kind of like
wiggle me out of the kitchen you're like
yeah I'll just do it myself so I like
this experience because there is no safe
coming out of you
it was the gratitude and I'm linguini so
that's your little chef yeah this is my
little shopper here you have no thing
it's starting to smell real good in here
and I like the fact that it's the smells
and I'm smelling aren't the usual sense
that we smell when I cook because I have
a go to like holy vision no it's not I
make up a while and that's very like
Asian it's cases it's somehow you have a
talent
we get like guilty infusion
and only you
they just you know what it is though
it's because my I based it very Asian
centric because my mom was the one I'm
talking to cook so when in doubt I go
back to my roots when it comes to
cooking and so by default it's gonna be
ginger and garlic all the way through
and I'm not complaining I'm just trying
to keep it real and no matter what [ __ ]
you cook it always tastes it has that
kc-10 uh that's on cash dome how do you
say in English like the flavor stable
every trademark sandwich your flavor
your signature flavor is Asian you know
what it is it's because I have the same
process in terms of how I sweat the
herbs and it's a very Asian style way of
sweating the flavors out I take the
garlic and I throw it in oil and I
literally have the garlic cooking and
oil
for like two minutes and sweat the
flavor out and plagues the oil that way
and then I use that flavored oil to cook
and that's a very Chinese thing to do
that's custom I feel like I'm courting a
cooking show look really you're the one
that's always cooking that's true you
should act really hectic and busy right
now so it's like iron chef's five
minutes to go five minutes ago and over
here chef Tiffany is sautéing up some
beets
all right I'm really proud of tip she
like I thought we were gonna tag-team
the process but she just took over and
she wishes cooking misses phenomenal if
she never cooks hey told you I can do
with experience
I was watching her cook and I saw how
how much fun she was having and like I
couldn't help but think this experience
has brought out a new beauty inner
you're talking about me like I'm not
even here I can hear you scratch that
she's tearing off play anyway so we're
coming to an end I mean she did a
fantastic job we're gonna play it in a
to-go box and one of those uh recall the
morning yeah
Neal crutch boxes we're always on the go
we never have time to actually sit down
like that that table is never used and
so we have some business to do at the
old JK office and so we're going to take
our meal preps to the JK office and
we'll eat together as a family at the
office with Isaac
we did it nice high five I did it you
did do it - Allah is supposed to look
like and we altered that and to this
version it's pretty good yeah really
close
looks just like except we just have a
different container for it can we just
try a little bit
try it go go go go go oh my god please /
call it ball do this is really good I
did it I want to try this I'm so happy
we're both jumping this is amazing oh
wow alright got that little kid right
now three time and you got out of school
you gotta go to the office alright so
now I'm at the JK office the old JK
office I haven't ever been here forever
this place looks crazy actually I don't
remember leaving like this at all
I think Joshua Barn have been using this
place for JK gamer
big clue BAM we didn't add this green
screen before another big blue BAM JK
gamer this is probably going to be old
news by the time this vlog goes up but
apparently a lot of you guys didn't like
the new set for JK news and apparently
even JK party as well but we agree
though I think there's still a lot of
stuff behalf of fix in terms of making
it feel a little more nostalgic in terms
of getting it closer to what it used to
be a lot of you guys noticed that audio
is really bad we agree the main reason
why we actually are going to move Jakob
news back to the old set is because the
audio is not ready we still need to
figure out a way in order to find the
proper audio quality that we would like
and in fact we're looking for that a
very crisp podcast kind of sound so
we're gonna work on that and
in the meantime while we're working on
that we're going to move Jake and News
back to the old set that's a familiar
angle isn't it so is this one and so is
this one what I'm here for is to set up
lighting so one of the reasons I wanted
a new set was we wanted to make everyone
looking a lot prettier with some actual
professional lighting and the kind of
lighting we have here right now are
these fluorescents so it casts very
over-the-top kind of look and then it
creates bags for people and can't see
their eyes everything is just starting
it looks great for like a dramatic movie
like a thriller you know if I was like a
assassin right now that kind of lighting
look really cool right now but we are a
comedy channel so we want to brighten up
their faces so we see everything I'm
tasking myself to create a lighting
setup that would benefit everyone in
Jake and news to look prettier TIFF and
Anna on their way as well TIFF just
picked up Isaac she's on her way here
they're gonna fix up the background cuz
it just looks like it looks like an
abandoned warehouse right now actually
and not alone anymore
thanks for the how cool tip is here once
and here Isaac's here yeah you're pretty
good yeah yeah so Tess made some lunch
today you made food I made it why cuz it
is also like a very very good chef how
do you know you never tried my food why
you telling you why I try your food all
the time
Eddie yeah you bring it over since I
barely hear all apologize yeah the
problem all the presentation kind of got
messed up but I made salmon oh it's like
cauliflower but I didn't I didn't like
actually create the recipe or anything
haven't ever so small there's like a
piece of mail here sticking over here if
you want
Bart hurting himself Bart would hurt
himself on that here look I said I can
get it it's tiny
no oh you know what I'll just ask for it
oh yeah went from housewife cooking the
meals for today - handyman of the
company oh there it is nice things
getting clogged at home oh that's a wild
oh yeah go to circle I wash just gotta
catch the river this is really talented
a lot of stuff I finally found one
things you can't do
all right well we are done setting up
the office revamp it's actually looking
pretty good back there but all we really
did was we did some tucking away and we
did some polishing polishing and tucking
and tuck and polish and sprinkle scary
wrinkles um something that is something
that that's what we did
yes there's my lighting setup I'm not
too sure this is actually gonna last
because I'm not too happy with the
actual lumination for the shots so work
in progress all right
magic trick commence trick hey wait how
was it that was it no hot tea yeah